tenemos que encontrar las ecuaciones
para las gráficas a b c y d así que te
invito a que hagas una pausa y que
pienses cómo encontrarías tú las
ecuaciones para estas gráficas ok
entonces una forma en la que podemos
empezar es ver que estas se parecen
muchísimo a las gráficas de ye igual a
la raíz cuadrada de x y eso es por lo
siguiente fíjate que si nos paramos en
este vértice y avanzamos 1 también
subimos 1 si avanzamos 4 es decir en 7
subimos 2 y así sucesivamente verdad si
avanzamos 9 avanzaremos hacia arriba 3
entonces puedes darte cuenta o
convencerte de que estas cuatro se
parecen muchísimo de hecho son son muy
parecidas a la función oa la gráfica de
la función igual a raíz de x entonces
pensemos en esa gráfica que tome estos
valores verdad en cero vale 0 en 1 vale
1 en 4 vale 2
en 9 vale 3 muy bien entonces digamos
tenemos este lo va a poner con rosa
tenemos esta gráfica
qué es la raíz cuadrada de x muy bien ok
entonces
si te das cuenta por ejemplo una muy muy
fácil o las dos más fáciles de ver son
las gráficas de de idea porque son
fáciles de ver por ejemplo a de x vamos
a ver qué pasa con a de x a de x es
exactamente la gráfica de la raíz
cuadrada de x de hecho lo voy a poner
con rosa para que quede más claro esta
es la raíz cuadrada de x sólo trasladada
hacia abajo 3 unidades y como vimos ya
en el vídeo pasado pues eso simplemente
es tomar la raíz cuadrada de x y
restarle 3 de tal suerte que cuando x
vale 0 en vez de estar en este punto va
a estar en menos 3 muy bien entonces ya
tenemos a de x vamos a ver qué ocurre
con de x donde evaluado en x bueno aquí
si te das cuenta está a la misma altura
sólo que estamos trasladando hacia la
derecha entonces tenemos que sacar una
raíz cuadrada no vamos a sumar porque
queremos mantenernos a la misma altura
tenemos que trasladar hacia la derecha y
ya vimos que si queremos trasladar hacia
la derecha tenemos que restar y cuánto
hay que restar pues tantas unidades como
hayamos trasladado que en este caso son
tres muy bien quizás esta es la parte
más anti intuitiva que podemos tener en
este tipo de ejercicios pero una vez que
ya los maneja uno es muy sencillo de
acordarse ahora bien vamos a ver qué
ocurre con vd x ok
para eso no tenemos que esto
esencialmente por ejemplo si nosotros
ponemos estaré aquí está de aquí
ok esta de aquí esta función es
exactamente raíz de equis pero
trasladada 3 hacia arriba verdad esto
sería raíz de x + 3 pero si nosotros
queremos reflejar o voltearla de esta
forma lo que teníamos que hacer es
multiplicar por menos 1 lo que está
dentro de la raíz cuadrada de tal suerte
que sólo esté definida para valores de
menores o iguales que 0 es decir para
valores no positivos muy bien entonces
vdx vdx será igual a la raíz cuadrada de
menos x menos x más 3 muy bien muy bien
ahora que ocurre con ce concede x vamos
a ponerlo con este color cede x
bien podría ser entonces si nos damos
cuenta tenemos que trasladar tres
unidades a la izquierda eso nos da raíz
de x + 3 recordemos que para trasladar a
la izquierda hay que hay que sumar
entonces voy a poner x + 3 pero estamos
definiendo para los valores de la
izquierda es decir a partir de menos 3
hacia atrás para todos los menores o
iguales que menos 3 lo estamos
definiendo entonces hay que ponerle un
menos verdad así que es el x + 3 tiene
que ser menor o igual que 0 o bien x
tiene que ser menor o igual que 3 y eso
es porque aquí es el menos multiplicando
muy bien y esto no lo estamos subiendo
ni ni bueno no lo estamos trasladando ni
hacia arriba ni hacia abajo así que esta
es la ecuación que corresponde a c de x
entonces lo que siempre es claro e
intuitivo es que si sumamos fuera de la
raíz cuadrada o si restamos estamos
trasladando hacia arriba si sumamos o
hacia abajo si restamos lo que
contraintuitivo es que si sumamos dentro
de la raíz en realidad nos estamos
trasladando a la izquierda como en este
caso pero
sí sí en vez de sumar restamos en como
en este segundo poco bueno como en el
caso de de x en realidad nos estamos
trasladando a la derecha eso ya lo vimos
con más cuidado en el vídeo anterior
solo es cosa de que lo practiques para
que tengas muy buena habilidad para
trabajar con estos con estas
traslaciones y estas reflexiones o bien
lo más fácil de pensar es ver cuando
esto que está dentro de la raíz cuadrada
se anula si vemos eso sería como el
equivalente encontrar este vértice